10 ways to immediately improve your
videos this law is packed full of
practical tips and here are a few great
communicators Bridge the success Gap and
relate to Their audience one of the most
powerful things you can do in your
videos is understand that people want to
know about your struggle before they are
open to learning from your success
videos that just brag or just talk about
the result without the struggle fall
flat from making a true connection with
viewers hopefully on YouTube if you are
sharing an answer to a problem if you're
helping people reach their goals you're
not just telling them the solution by
the way that will please people and
there's no reason you can't get views
from that but if you want to strengthen
your content you want to bridge the
success Gap are you articulating your
struggle think about it when you hear a
public speaker if all they get up on
stage and do is brag about how
successful they are it actually builds a
wall but if at first they relate that
they've been there they've struggled
they've also been through the process
and through pain and trial and hardship
they have found a solution and now they
want to share that solution with you if
you can weave that into your content
it'll be more powerful start any message
by understanding your audience's
perspective here's the question before
you sit down and outline your video do
you truly understand who you're audience
is do you truly understand their
feelings emotions needs we say at think
media the Creator who understands the
viewer best wins so if you're going to
start a video you want to understand
your audience's desires perspective
point of view beliefs and the big
mistake is 99% of content creators don't
even know who they're making content for
and even if they think they do a lot of
times there's a disconnect in that area
identify an operate within your strength
zones for credibility it's a good
content tip if you try to create content
about something you're not strong at
you're going to lose to somebody who's
stronger at that content personally I
try to stay in my Lane there's a lot of
things where I'm happy to go on a video
podcast and be interviewed about and
there's many things where I have no clue
about when I think about my strength
zones if you want to talk about YouTube
let's go if you want to talk about
business let's go marketing let's go if
you want to talk about the Bible let's
go if you want to talk about politics I
don't know if you want to talk about pop
culture I kind of know I'm not going to
go work at BuzzFeed I'm not going to go
work at TMZ those are not my strength
zones or my passion zones and so you're
going to have maximum credibility when
you operate within your strength Zone
have a clear thesis for your message
it's the core of communication are you
starting each video with a clear thesis
and one of the things I loved about this
book is again I was thinking about how
it applied to YouTube videos but you
don't hear a lot of people using that
language which it reminded me being back
in English class in high school I was
like that's true a video should have a
clear thesis it should have a core to
its communication and are you trying to
communicate too many things in one video
is the point unclear in the video is
your communication generally foggy
Clarity is power so do you have a clear
thesis another Point here is research is
crucial both for specific talks and for
continued personal growth one of the
ways to power up your content is to
improve your research so how can you
invest more in research develop your
skill of research and I liked that John
highlighted the benefit of it not just
being powerful for the content itself
but also helpful for your continual
growth one of the things I love about
doing this podcast one of the things I
love because I actually am passionate
about YouTube and video marketing and so
social media is I've created a job that
I enjoy doing meaning I like to research
about YouTube but when I do I get
smarter and I grow my knowledge and I
include that in videos and you get to
benefit and I get stronger hopefully the
content get gets better it's cool to be
in a position where the the the
monetization loop is helpful to fund
being able to do this full-time and I
know that that's also what your
aspiration is as well in your particular
area but I want to encourage you the
development of the skill of research and
the inclusion of good research in your
content will make it stronger outlining
provides a structure for your message
can you outline your videos numbering
your points and a lot of times I like to
outline and have numbers so the
structure to the content and then
pneumonic devices could be something
like in our Tech episode we talked about
AVL audio video lighting maybe your
points are connected to a framework of
something some kind messages using
research illustrations and stories from
your own life there's a couple ways to
power things up and I love this every
message is like an airplane flight
requiring a successful takeoff and
Landing good takeoffs can be built using
questions quotes connections while
Landings should summarize and empower
the audience now there is an old joke
here on the podcast and that think media
that I'm always Landing the plane and
that I'm you know know uh taxing to the
uh to the the terminal and that we're
stuck on the tarmac and that we're
circling the airport and this joke that
I can't land the plane but every message
is like an airplane flight and those are
some powerful tips for hooks can you
open with a question can you open with a
powerful quote can you open by making
some kind of connection of course the
goal in communication is to connect with
the viewer here on YouTube and so we've
already covered a lot and we have two
full more laws to go through and the
four primary connection points but
here's a summary of the bullets I just
hit can you relate in your content do
you understand your audience's
perspective can you play to your
strength zones do you have a clear
thesis are you doing your research do
you have a good outline for your content
are you numbering your points can you
include illustrations can you include
stories and every communication is like
an airplane flight there's 10 little
nuggets under the law of content I think
we can all improve our content this is a
cheat code for content at ators if your
videos can be more authentic and you're
not faking it you're comfortable in your
own skin you figured out your own voice
when you've got empathy for the viewer
and that's communicated through the
camera when you're speaking from the
heart and you're being genuine and this
might take some time to develop not only
in the skill of communication but
getting aligned with the topics you're
covering with your channel
topic
help involves offering practical advice
and tools for change this is probably
one that I lean to I want to develop
them all but I am obsessed with crafting
content that's actually helpful that's
value based that ansers specific
questions that solve specific problems
humor is about seeing the lighter side
of life and connecting through laughter
if you have a gift of humor that's a
powerful way to improve your content
hope entails showing future
possibilities inspiring belief in a
better future maybe some people you
watch because you feel encouraged after
strengthened after your purpose in
watching is to get your mind right your
motivation up to get your mood shifted
your emotions charged and so four
elements heart help humor and hope one
of those is probably your strongest but
if you improve even marginally all four
and have a heartfelt message that solves
someone's problem that makes them laugh
in the process and that ends with giving
them hope talk about a powerful message
a powerful YouTube video if you enjoy
this podcast and are ready for some deep
dive YouTube strategy just go to think
masterclass.com to get access to my
1hour on demand YouTube strategy class
you'll be looking over my shoulder as I
share my best tips and you can watch it
on Demand right now at think
masterclass.com